[Müzik]
Merhabalar Öncelikle hepiniz hoş
geldiniz o meşhur soru gelecek nesil
hala dünyada yaşıyor olacak mı gelecek
dünyadan neler olacak bugün
naçizane kendi deneyimlerimden de yola
çıkarak bu konuya biraz parmak basmaya
çalışacağım
Evet bunu Aslında sosyal medyadan da Bir
sorduk Biz gelecek dünyada sizce neler
olacak dediğimizde daha çok teknoloji
daha çok bilim gelişmiş dünya az Emek
teknolojinin kullanımıyla daha az yemek
sarf ederek daha fazla teknolojinin
kullanımı bolca tüketim bir yerde konu
kuraklığa su sorunlarına küresel gıda
krizine iklim krizine falan da geldi
çünkü özellikle son 2-3 yıldır pandemi
üzerine gıda krizi iklim krizi gibi
konular tüm insanlığın yönünü birazıma
ve dünya problemlerine çevirmiş durumda
Diğer taraftan bilgi bilgi her zaman
önemli tabii ki hepimizin
bilgi ile besleniyoruz Sonuçta teknoloji
özellikle teknolojiyi hepimiz aç olarak
istediğimizi gördük sosyal medyadan da
yaptığımız araştırmalara sorularımızın
cevaplarına göre Peki bu soruyu Biraz
daha değiştirdiğimiz bulunan bir gün
dünyamızdan ayrılmak zorunda kalacak
mıyız diye sorayım ben sizlere buraya da
bir film koydum bu film naçizane Biraz
benim kendimi de gördüm bir film tdx
ekibi arkadaşlar bana bu konuyla
geldiklerinde aklımda ilk yıldızlararası
canlanmıştı ki bunu da özellikle
anlatmak isteyerek buraya koydum
Yıldızlar arasındaki hikaye şu tarımdan
başlıyor çünkü
sektörün insanlığın bilginin temeli
tarım Öncelikle beslenebiliyor olmamız
lazım ki sonra üzerine hizmet sektörünü
inşa edelim sonra bilimi teknolojiyi ve
uzay teknolojisini inşa edelim Burada da
yine tarımdaki ve dünyadaki belli başlı
problemlerden yola çıkarak insanlık
Yıldızlar arası seyahatlerle başka
dünyalar arıyor ve günün sonunda orada
bir dünya buluyorlar Ee ne yazık ki
dünyamızdan ayrılmak zorunda kalıyoruz
filmde anlatıldığı gibi ama burada benim
asıl parmak bas Maya çalıştığım nokta
asıl ön plana çıkarmaya çalıştığım nokta
şu; tarımı teknolojiyi ve bu filmde de
gördüğümüz gibi uzay teknolojilerini
dünyamızdan ayrılmak zorunda kalmayacak
şekilde geliştirelim geliştirmeye devam
edelim olacak
dünyanın geçmişine baktığımızda Big
bang'den bu yana büyük patlamadan bu
yana yaklaşık 14 milyar yıllık bir
hikayesi var bunun son 150-200 yılında
Biz Teknoloji geliştiriyoruz insanlık
olarak
burada
dünyamızda teknolojimizi geliştirirken
kardeş ev ölçeğine göre
dünyasına ve gezegenine hükmeden birinci
grup işte galaksisine hükmeden sistemine
hükmeden ikinci grup tüm evrene ve
galaksiye hükmeden 3 grup olarak
adlandırılıyor burada enerji tüketimi
enerji
ihtiyacı göz önünde bulundurularak
ortaya konulmuş bir ölçek bu aslında
bilgi de bir yerde enerji olduğu için
teknolojide bir yerde enerji olduğu için
Bugün biz bilgiye ve enerjiye olan
açlığımızla aslında bir yerde baktığınız
zaman dünyamızı da tüketiyoruz diye
özellikle anlatmak istedim burayı
İnsanlık da bir yerde Aslında dünyanın
hikayesi gibi bir insanı anlatırken
dünyanın da büyüdüğünü geliştiğini Tıpkı
gençlik çocukluk ve yaşlılık gibi bir
süreçten geçtiğini anlatabiliriz burada
dünyayı ve insanı birlikte ele almak
istiyorum çünkü
14 milyar gibi büyük bir zamanın çok
kısa bir süresince bir teknoloji
geliştirirken neden faydalanmışız
dediğimiz kalıtım Bilgiden Yani bugün
ben buradaysam babamın Çiftçi olmasından
dolayı çiftçilik bilgisini babamdan
babamın 60 yıl boyunca öğrendiği süreci
bir veya iki yıl gibi çok kısa bir
sürede öğrenmemden dolayı buradayım gibi
Aslında insanlık Anadolu tabiriyle
birbirine el veriyor yani teknolojiyi
bilgiyi birikimi Biz her zaman hem
kalıtımsal olarak hem de anlatarak
çocuklarımıza ve yeni nesle aktarıyoruz
burada teknolojiyi de tabii konumuz
teknoloji gelecek dünya bunu da ufak bir
şekilde belirttikten sonra biraz böyle
teknoloji ve toplum bugüne nasıl gelmiş
Onları anlatalım endüstri 4-0 hepimiz
biliyoruz özellikle Avrupa Birliği'nin
işareti ettiği 2015 ile 2020 yılları
arasında tüm dünyanın dijital dönüşüm
nesnelerin interneti Bulut bağlantısı ve
benzeri gibi Global teknolojilerinin
anlattığı anlatıldığı ve özellikle
sadece fabrika üretim sektör dikey
bazında yapılan bir çalışma Fakat bunun
diğer tarafları da var tarım tarafı var
tarım 4-0 örneği şu an çok çalışılıyor
tarım 5-0 gelecekte çalışmaya
başlayacağımız konular olarak
adlandırılıyor ama biz bugünden bunu
çalışıyoruz Aslında
toplumda Bir taraftan gelişirken biz
tekerleğin icadından
günümüzde bilgi çağına Bulut bağlantılı
birçok otonomi çözümlerine varıncaya
kadar tarımı geliştirmişiz teknoloji
gelişmiş teknoloji geliştirmişiz toplum
gelişmiş toplumun geliştirmişiz tekrar
teknoloji ve tarım gelişmiş Aslında bu
bir Silsile Bu bir hiç durmadan
genişleyen büyüyen bir kar topu bu
çalışmaları yaparken biraz da böyle tam
tüm dünyanın exponansiyel olarak arttığı
nüfusunun arttığı ve tam böyle sabahki
oturumlarda da bahsedildi Sanayi
Devriminin olduğu dönemlerde yüksek
üretime karşın yüksek insan
insanların yüksek üreme hızına da karşın
bir yerde Aslında Dünya nüfusu artarken
tarımsal üretimdeki kaynaklarımızın
yetmeyeceği gibi bir öngörü ortaya
koyulmuş İngiliz nüfus bilimci tamıs
maltes tarafından fakat biraz önceki
bahsettiğim o kartopu o Silsile ile
teknoloji ve tarımın birlikte
gelişmesiyle Biz tüm insanlık olarak
1940'lı ve 70'li yıllar arasında
teknolojiyi tarıma uyarladığımız zaman
bu problemin önüne geçebilmişiz ve tüm
dünya yeşile büründüğü için ekilebilir
araziler çok fazla olduğu için Her yer
yeşil olduğu için bunun adı Green
rivalution olarak yeşil büyüme olarak
literatüre geçmiş Yani buradaki öngörüyü
Aslında tüm insanlık olarak kırabil
Burada da bunun örneklerini görüyorsunuz
Aslında kısaca bahsetmek gerekirse
ülkemizden örnek verelim 1940'da bir
çiftçi 4 kişi besleyebilirken 2016'da 30
kişiyi besleyebilir hale gelmişiz bunu
ne ile yapmışız geleneksel mekanik
teknolojisi ile geleneksel hidrolik
elektronik teknolojileri ile
yapabilmişiz şu an bu teknolojiler
teknoloji bariyerini doldurmuş Doymuş
durumda bir yerde Aslında mekaniği daha
fazla eğip bükemeyeceğimiz de tüm
insanlık olarak anladık gelecek dünyada
Aslında bugünkü mekanik no havanın
üzerine çok fazla bir şey koymamıza
gerek yok gibi bir algı var Tüm
teknoloji camiasında bunun da üzerine
yazılımlarla Aslında teknolojiyi
geliştiriyor olmamız gerekiyor burada
konuşmamın en başında da söylediğim çok
hızlı tüketim har vurup harman savurma
gibi konulardan dolayı teknolojiyi son
150 yılda çok agresif olarak
geliştirdiğimiz için tüm karanlık olarak
dünyamızı ve geçmişimizi unutmuşuz Tıpkı
2020'ye kadar Tarımı ve üretimi besini
unuttuğumuz gibi
2020'den itibaren Aslında tüm dünya
sürdürülebilirlik net Zero karbon food
print ve benzeri gibi konuları iklim
gibi konuları ki benden sonraki seçimde
de o devreye alınacak Selin hanım
tarafından
unutmuşuz yönümüzü tekrar buraya döndük
Neden Çünkü pandemi bize hatırlattı
besinlerin insanlığın temel kaynağı olan
aslında temel ihtiyacı olan besinlerin
üretimin yetmediği durumda Biz
ilerleyemiyoruz uzaya çıkamıyoruz Çünkü
o ihtiyacımızı gideremiyoruz tıpkı bir
barınacağımız ev olmadığında işimizin de
olmaması gibi bir durumdan bahsediyorum
burada Dünyamız da aslında bizim
barınacağımız bir evimiz bu zamana kadar
geliştirdiğimiz teknolojiler Aslında
dünyamızı biraz iklim ve benzeri gibi
konularda çok yormuşuz yıpratmışız
topraklarımızı çok Çorak hale getirmişiz
gereksiz kimyasal kullanarak gereksiz
ilaç kullanarak gereksiz gübre
kullanarak Bundan sonra artık
sürdürülebilirlik mottosu sürekli
söyleniyor
sürdürülebilirlik kapsamında çalışmalar
yapmamız lazım deniyor ama bunu nasıl
yapacağız Bunu teknoloji ile yapacağız
yine gelecek dünyada kendimizin nerede
görüyorsak gelecekte hangi teknolojileri
geliştiriyor olacaksak onlarla yapacağız
diyoruz burada tarımdan birkaç örnek
koymak istedim Tabi ki bu tarz
teknolojiler geliştirmeyelim yani her
zaman doğayı gözeten
teknolojiler gelişirim diye örnek olarak
koymak istedim yine burada insanların
çalıştığı gibi teknolojiler de
geliştirmeyelim yani Mekanik bir yere
kadar Aslında oradaki o patatesleri Eken
yazılım makinaları yazılımlarla çalışan
mekanik işbirliği ile çalışan makineler
olabilir mekanik teknolojisi gelmiş bir
yere duvara dayanmış ve sonu gelmiyor
artık bundan sonra yazılımla çalışmamız
lazım derken tarz örneklerden
bahsediyordum bugün tüm dünyanın Neyi
konuşuyor gereksiz kimyasal kullanarak
çoraklaştırdığımız topraklarımızda
Sadece ihtiyacın kadar kimyasal kullan
ve sadece yabancı otun Üzerine ilaç sık
sadece
bitkinin üzerine besin elementi sık gibi
konuları konuşuyor Bu da aslında net
Zero ve
sürdürülebilirlik motorlarından birisi
otonom traktörleri konuşuyor tüm dünya
otomatik hasat yapan fabrikaları
konuşuyor bakın endüstri 4-0 kapsamında
2015-2020 motosu fabrikalarda
2020'den sonrasında Aslında Motto ve tüm
dünyanın döndüğü yer yine Fabrikalar ama
tarıma dayalı Fabrikalar Bu da aslında
yine geleceği şekillendirecek olan
teknolojilerden birisi
temelde Doğa ana bulunurken yani tarım
ve insanlığın besin kaynağı insanlığın
ürettiği en basit bir Buğday Tanesi
bulunurken onun üzerinde endüstri onun
üzerinde hizmet ve onun üzerinde ileri
teknolojiler uzaya gitmek Tıpkı
yıldızlararası filminde bulunduğu gibi
diğer bir galaksiye diğer bir gezegene
gitmek konularında ele aldığımız bu
yerde bugün
tarımın haricinde diğer teknolojilerden
de bahsediyoruz işte Hyper lup
elektrikli uçan arabalar ki geçtiğimiz
haftalarda
Global fuarlardan Dubai cayteks'teydim
orada bir denemesi dahi yapıldı Uçan
arabanın metaforce'den nft'den yeni
nesil teknolojilerden çok fazla
bahsediliyor Fakat benim bu konuşmamda
özellikle gelecek dünya konuşmasında
alanımın da domainiminde gereği biraz
böyle tarıma dikkat çekmeyi
istedim özellikle burada Bu
teknolojileri hepimiz görüyoruz ama
tarım çok fazla bilinmiyor buradan
tekrar konuyu oraya bağlayayım gelecek
bilimci Alvin tafları diyor ki
var tarım yani kırsal kentli köylü sabah
doğan başaran'da söyledi ve tüketici
metropollerde yaşayan insanlar
birbirlerinden çok ayrı fakat gelecekte
prozyummer adında bir kavramla üreten
tüketici ürettiği kadar tüketen
tüketiciye kadar üreten efektif
üretimden bahsediyoruz bir tüketici
kavramı ortaya çıkacak diyor gelecek
bilimci 3 dalga kitabında bunu Biz
nerelerde kullanabiliriz Aslında bu
bilim kurgu filmlerinde falan da sürekli
görüyoruz uzaya çıktığımızda
kolonileştirmekten bahsediyoruz biz
farklı gezegenleri Çünkü dünyamızda
kaynaklarında azaldığını tüm dünya
görüyor bir gün bir karış dahi ekecek
toprağımız bulunmadığında gidip Mars'a
patates dahi ekmemiz gerekebilecek bunu
prozyumur kavramından yola çıkarak
düşündüğümüzde kaç kişi orada
yaşayacaksa o kadar üretim yapılmalı kaç
kişinin besine ihtiyacı varsa o besinler
kadar
üretimlerin olması lazım ve o insanların
o kadar tüketmesi gerekiyor gibi bir
fizibilite çalışmasından bahsediyor
geçtiğimiz yıllarda yine hepimiz Gördük
Bir yıl soğan para etmedi üreticinin
elinde kaldı Ertesi yıl soğan çok para
etti
stopçular da bu defa kaldı arz talep
dengesini bir türlü sağlayamadık Aslında
frozenur kavramı burada tam anlamıyla
tarım politikalarının üretimin
teknolojinin nasıl kullanılması
gerektiğini anlatıyor
burada son olarak bu patatesli filmden
bir örnek koymak istedim
Bu da sana kapak olsun Neil Armstrong
diyor Bunu da yine konunun başına
bağlayacağım ben nasıl bağlayacağım
Aslında bugün teknoloji Bizler
geliştiriyorsak bizden bir önceki
nesilden bir adım daha ileride
geliştiriyoruz bunu hiçbir zaman
unutmayarak yola devam etmemiz
gerektiğini söylemek istiyorum gelecek
dünyada daha fazla teknolojik şeyler
görmek istiyorsak tarımı hiçbir zaman
unutmamamız ve teknoloji her zaman
tarımda uygulamamız gerektiğini söylemek
için bunları aktarmak istedim kalıtım
bilgiye her zaman İnanın malkom gladwell
ben bir girişimciyim bu zamana kadar ki
hayatımda çok fazla okudum özellikle
Google mühendislerinin kitaplarını
Microsoft'un ve benzeri falan diğer
firmaların çok böylesi iyi olan
kitaplarını okuma fırsatı buldum ama
hepsinin bir kenara koyun malkom
gladwell isminde bir yazar var diyor ki
ki 10.000 saat kuralı Ben bir İşte
ustayım diyebilmeniz için on bin saat
onun üzerine çalışmış olmanız gerekiyor
diye diyor ve bu Yaklaşık 16 yıla
tekabül ediyor Biz de bir işte mühendis
işte bir doktor oldum diyene kadar zaten
20 yıl okumuş oluyoruz Aslında
başladığınız işi ve annenizin babanızın
yaptığı işi devam ettiriyor olursanız
kalıtım bilgiye inanarak çalışıyor
olursanız daha sağlıklı daha dünyamızı
gözetir daha Teknolojik ürünleri gelecek
nesillere aktaracağımız topraklarımızın
da bulunduğu şekilde el birliğiyle
geliştiriyor olabiliriz diyeceğim
teşekkür ediyorum hepinize
[Alkış]
[Müzik]